what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel welcome to
morning coffee Bots where I tell you my
thoughts in the morning while I drink
coffee actually today I'm drinking chai
tea
um everyone in the comments last time
was telling me chai is just tea well
guys
um when I go to Starbucks and I order a
chai tea
um they give me this sugar milky
goodness so I don't know what it is but
it's not just straight tea
and I'm trying to be healthier so I make
it at home now so it's like less sugary
anyways before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos also
um
sign up for my memberships
um on the second tier you get access to
my Discord and behind the scenes Vlogs
third tier um you connect with me on
social media fourth tier
um you get a one-on-one call with me
once a month so if you feel like
the these aren't enough you know you
just want more Pearl
sign up for the one-on-one call anyways
what are we talking about today so
I want to talk about modern women
um
and it's like such an interesting
phenomenon
that we have going on oh wait hold on
let me close my door hold on
okay sorry
um it's such an interesting phenomenon
that we have going on
um
we live in this culture where
our mothers and wives are me me me me
first
um and it's just interesting because
when I was growing up my mom always told
me like once you have kids it's not
about you anymore so if you want to be
selfish so like do that before you have
kids because when you have kids like
your whole life changes and it's not
about you and she also made sure I knew
that my life isn't over if I have kids
like a lot of I just saw a video the
other day and this woman was saying like
her life was over and I'm thinking like
my my parents still did all the same
[ __ ] when
I mean don't get me wrong I'm sure their
lives were different but like we got to
travel the world like I grew up
going to
um a different National Park every
summer and I know everyone's gonna say
well that's because you guys were rich
and I'm like well we weren't always rich
and we always made sure to like my
parents would like show us whatever they
could so it would be a national park you
know like how expensive is that to go
camping with your family
but it's like modern women would rather
just go to the club and I'm like what is
wrong with you people
like don't get me wrong
my family drinks we'll go to the bar but
we'll go to the bar with our brothers
like it is not the I I don't drink but
like my family does and
it is not
it and and the other thing is I I'm so
interesting to hear this phenomenon of
women leaving when they're not like
happy and I'm just thinking
what if my mom left my dad when she
wasn't had I'm like
because you're not like [ __ ] your
happiness your happiness doesn't even
matter and then people say like you're
young you don't know how life isn't sure
I'm
I am Young You Know hands up hands up
but it's just like I don't need that
much life experience to know that
leaving because you're not happy is
selfish when you have children like
after the kids are out of the house
I feel like fair game do what you want
but you may you have a responsibility to
those children to raise them in a
two-parent home
and I just can't
believe the selfishness of modern day
women and like their kids are like their
handbags like it's really weird I'll
look at their Instagrams and it's like
thought thought pictures okay and then
their kid is like a handbag I've never
really been into like thoughty pictures
I'm
you know I'm sure maybe here and there
I'll show a little too much like I'm
tall okay but I'm like why is your ass
on Instagram and you have a son
man like you have a son
a child it
like I cannot if my mom was out here
posting ass pictures
oh my God I would die inside I would die
inside that would be so embarrassing
that would be so embarrassing that's the
thing like modern day women want
everything to be about them
they need to be the center of attention
even when they have children when it's
like literally not about you anymore
and that's what I see as a lot of
problems in the dating market like I I
think men have their issues too and I
know this isn't popular to say but like
I men have been feminized and Men
um I don't I think there's a lot more
like simps than there's ever been but I
think it starts with the women
um like I don't think that
I don't think the the way that men are
now would have happened if it weren't
for the women and it really makes me
think like what happened to our
generation and I genuinely feel like our
generation is the way it is because we
were raised by selfish women
and so because we were raised by selfish
women like were like our generation is
very narcissistic like I was reading the
definition of a narcissist and I swear
to God it reminded me of the modern
women I've talked to on my show I swear
to God
it's like a grandiose
um like self-importance like something
like that I'm like God damn
all these [ __ ] that think they're
tens I think they're tens
why on Earth would you like that's the
other thing
yeah why on Earth would you think you're
a 10.
like Tom Brady's wife in her prime that
was ten that was a 10. you look like her
no okay
all this like self-love [ __ ] oh my
God I'm so tired of hearing about
self-love
you guys love yourself enough let me
tell you modern women
I swear to God do you love yourself
enough you you la you love yourself more
than your husband you love yourself more
than your children and you love yourself
more than your community and your duty I
swear to God
modern women
you you have enough self-love to go
around I swear to Jesus
I swear I swear to Jesus
and I'm not just trying to [ __ ] on
Modern women like I do want to create
Solutions
and
some of the solutions I've talked about
on the channel
my first goal is to get 2 million
subscribers um because I feel like once
I get
enough like Revenue into the channel I
can invest it into other things so one
of the solutions that I want to come up
with is I want to have a wife school and
this is for women like how are women
supposed to know how to be wives if they
weren't raised by wives
um and a lot of girls like they think
they can like become it's really weird
they think they can just like become
feminine by like watching some courses
and like I'm like
I don't really see that working like I
think you need to be around Ellie stop
it stop stop snoring stop it
um I think you need to be around like
women that were actually wives and know
how to get along with a man and
um
because of that
like I want to make a wife school and I
want to get I wouldn't even people were
like are you gonna teach it I'm like no
I need a wife look what you mean no I
want to get I want to get people that
have like 20 30 years of marriage
experience 40 50 whatever it is like and
there's like courses on how how to like
get along with a man how to like stroke
a guy's ego how um to be a guy's piece
and
um cooking cleaning like just stuff that
like I would when I do it I'm gonna get
like a list of like what things guys
want from a wife
um
and I want to make a school
to help
create wives again because what are you
supposed to do with the modern women
um some will just die alone and be
homeless and that's fine but like some
actually I do think want to change and
have just been misled and I really want
to be a part of like the solution that
can bring like men and women back
together
um
even you can even do like honest ratings
on there where like I show guys girls
and it's not meant to like break your
ego but like ask them like would you
date her based on her looks is she good
looking enough for you to be with
because I think as women like a lot of
times we can play attention with
um
um a trap like like we think that we're
on the level of the guys we get
attention from and we're just not and I
think you know maybe honest
conversations about like where you fall
and what guys would actually date you
um
I think could could be helpful I don't
know could be could be
um you know femininity classes and
um I'm not I'm not gonna sell anything I
haven't done so anything I but this is
this is how I think like I'm just very
solution oriented
and I was also trying to think of like a
school for men
um and I don't know exactly what I would
put in that school I would not be the
one teaching it but you know you could
do a school on like game and you could
do a school on like
setting boundaries with the ground you
could get all the red pill coaches to
like come in and like coach these people
in person and you pay x amount of
dollars and you can come once a year and
like I don't know this is just a working
idea so don't don't quote me on this
but the thing is like how many women
have really pursued a man
more than a degree right
how many women are really going to put
the dreams of the family above above
Ellie sorry my dog's snoring
so I don't know let me know in the
comments sorry this is kind of a rant
but let me know in the comments what
Solutions you see that could bring men
and women back together
um
let me know
how
you would like how would you fix this
sort of problem and
let me know what you think can can
modern women be saved are there any is
there any is there any saving mode of
women modern women
um subscribe to the channel like the
video on your way out and I will talk to
you next time
[Music]